[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thanks for joining me
today
sporting the podcast I have a puppy and
it's uh it's my hours of sleep have
diminished
uh it's a lot and uh trying to balance
life and all that stuff Ryan but cute as
hell huh cute
as all hell I mean it's just like I
can't stop holding him and kissing him I
love that when I come here he like comes
like glumping down the stairs and he
doesn't know how to use his legs yet oh
my gosh he's so cute it is so it's not
cute when he shits in his crate no
that's but he only did that once and I
left because I left him like for three
and a half hours and I made the mistake
of feeding him before so I didn't get
mad at him but uh it was uh anyway
thanks for all the support and love you
know this podcast depends mostly on
patrons and uh you guys listening uh our
listeners are are loyal go to
patreon.com inside of you become a
patron I'll message you and uh you guys
really helped they really help and
thanks for listening if you're here for
Kristen Ritter you've come to the right
place uh we did a project together she's
amazing I just went to a concert with
her we're like best I'm like her gay
best friend that's what I am people like
oh Chris don't like no no no no no no no
we're we're buddies and uh yeah she's
awesome and what a what a talent uh Ryan
what are the handles at inside of you
pod on Twitter inside me podcasts on
Instagram and Facebook that's right the
inside of you online stores also we got
uh Lex statues of me there are only five
left and they were made they're bronze
two
twenty
down into this big they're big they're
nice and then they're signed by me and
there's a bunch of other Smallville
stuff and uh and insidey stuff brand new
big tumblers that are awesome so check
it out inside of you online store and uh
my band sunspan we're playing so I
really would appreciate the new album
came out never is what it is streaming
everywhere
um go to sunspin.com for more
information or if you want tickets to
our show it's a virtual show so you can
watch from your home and we lit we read
messages and we respond to you and we
play a bunch of songs and there's prizes
it's a lot of fun so if you want to
support the band
go to sunspin.com or go to stageit.com
and type in sunspin so
very fun that's very cool yeah and uh
that is that concert that we're doing
the virtual is May 6th Saturday at 5 p.m
Pacific Standard time so please if you
haven't listened please give it a chance
I know a lot of you guys listen you're
like I'm not listening to your band but
maybe if you haven't you could try and I
think you'd like it
whatever
uh yeah that's about it I think we
should just do this I think we should
get into Kristen Ritter it's my point of
view
you're listening to inside of you
youth Michael arose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience uh right before we started
rolling you said that you know you don't
do a lot of these but you you're really
private yeah I am I I'm not like a huge
fan of doing a bunch of interviews
because I get like nervous about it and
you know sometimes I don't love extra
attention on myself or you know things
like get picked up but I
want to support you and come do it we've
been talking about doing this interview
for for a long time like over two years
yeah I bumped into you a couple times
whether it was our good friend Davey
rovesque's screening of Night books yeah
but even way before that I think no it
was uh you were walking your child down
in Melrose and I was like hey I love
running into you I ran into them at a
concert too yes Bruce Springsteen I've
never gone to a Bruce Springsteen
concert was it Morrissey no was it uh
The Cure
was it uh anything it was LA Downtown
big place
La Hollywood Bowl
Greek no something downtown if it wasn't
an 80s band there's a good chance it
wasn't me no it was definitely you were
wearing your leather jacket leather
jacket yeah
this would have been like a really long
time ago and is it a sports game instead
did I run into you at the Lakers or
something maybe it was the Lakers game
it was a Lakers game I've been to one
Lakers game I think that might have been
it because I only remember the like
meeting and it was like outside with all
like the doors to a big event space
might have been that could have been or
a Rams game definitely not around no I
only went to one we could do this all
day folks and you're probably gonna shut
up no but like you know I always love
seeing you too and it's funny because
you're one of those people you can run
into and it's like no time is fast yeah
I just was talking about to a friend
about that because I don't I don't ever
like nothing's ever weird with me yeah I
don't feel like I'm like hey let's get
let's go yeah if there's yeah
um really nice easy person to get along
with let's just let the production I
mean I would say yes I mean I'm not the
easiest person in the world I don't
think any of us are that easy when
people really get to know us and know
our little idiosyncrasies and their
little you know our little [__]
traits and dark underbellies yeah those
nobody really wants to see that right
you have to keep some of it private sure
I mean there's some things about you
that you think that oh my God if they
knew that they would just look at me so
differently sure sure there are yeah of
course things you do things certain ways
you act certain you know just things
absolutely say we're not going too
private I mean those aren't that private
those are little characteristics of what
makes us human yeah but um no I loved
working with you we worked together and
I noticed you were unlike someone I've
ever worked with anyone I've ever worked
with being that you had just it's not
that people I've worked with don't have
a confidence you know an air about them
how they handle hold themselves but you
I remember you're so easy going so like
present with everybody but you never
seemed
nervous about the work or intense about
the work it was just that's work Works
part of me here we go are you always
like that I just was a it was
intimidating in a way because you were
so just on and it was natural and it was
effortless at least that's how I
perceived it
um thank you
um this last compliment I'm giving you
that's okay no um I appreciate that
because I I do feel like when I'm at
work when I'm on set when I'm like doing
a show that is probably where I'm the
most myself
um because I love it and I work hard at
it and I'm ready when I get there like I
have a exhaustive sort of prep process
and then I throw it all away once I'm on
set and I'm just there and so I I
appreciate that you saw me that way
um because that's kind of
yeah that's how you feel that's how yeah
that's how so are you saying that
there's sort of a juxtaposition of like
you're on set that's your world and
confidentness but in the real world
maybe you're not as you know I think I'm
not as with the like publicity side of
it and doing interviews and like the
Press support that you have to do for
projects why is that you think you know
it just feels like a different kind of
attention on you it feels like much more
pressure it feels like
um more personal I guess and when you're
playing a character you are you get to
hide behind that and like you're acting
and it's a performance and that's kind
of where my strength is and then when it
gets to like you know the personal stuff
I always start just like get I get
anxiety I sort of shut down okay what do
I say what do I do I hate when things
like
I sometimes you don't want attention on
things
that see that this is this is normal
this is like you know
um when you do red carpets I bet you
hate that I don't mind the red carpet
why is that because I but you have to
pose like Kristen Kristen over here
Kristen you have to put that little
mouth kind of chin thing down and yeah
and everybody does it ever all the women
the actresses all the dudes you have to
kind of you know what how you look good
and you have to do that yeah but do you
ever get mad at yourself or why am I
putting that on
if you don't put it on like if I don't
do like something you're gonna look like
I look like an idiot I look stupid
because I I don't photograph as easily
easy easily as well as you do and so I
get a little bit like I have to go
um we're at goofy or something I don't
mind the red carpet the photographs I'm
like I before I was an actress I was a
model so I had that like kind of built
into the work like that's part of the
work for me
um it's the interview Parts afterwards
it's the talk shows it's those things
that like you know what's the first
interview you have to say who it was but
do you ever have one experience where
you're like um I'm done
um I didn't not one that I was I was
like I'm done but I feel like you know
whenever you're supporting a project and
you have to do like the talk show
circuit I would always just put so much
pressure on myself and I'd be like in
the dressing room like like panicking
breaking out in hives and sweating and
nobody would sort of believe me or like
validate that because they'd be like you
got this Kristen your interviews are
always great you got this and I'm like
no really I'm I'm so nervous I can't do
it I can't do it but then you do it and
you like work the nerves you use the
nerves to like make a cute appearance
and then it's over and then everyone's
like see you got this but
it's the cyclical thing yeah it doesn't
it just even though it's validated at
the end like great Greg you go right
back into that same feeling yes and
there's only there's one time I was
doing like a tour for my book and I was
about to go like speak in front of
people at Barnes and Noble
right I was very nervous I felt so much
pressure I was so scared I was shaking
and the there was a person there a
publicist person
um who said like okay if you really feel
like you're gonna throw up or faint just
look at me and I'll come get you and
that was so disarming to me because then
I was like I felt validated I felt like
okay I have a Lifeline I'm gonna be okay
so that's like the one like thing that I
had sort of remembered see you're not
getting private but you're getting real
and you're talking about that which is
to me yeah is helpful helpful I think
it's important for people to know that
like what what sometimes might look
really easy for somebody there is
actually not yeah and when things are
still like really really hard do it
anyway you're gonna be okay
you don't have to have like level 10
confidence to like go after something
because sometimes we're all Faking It
that's true I get I get that and I get
that
you talk about validation yeah that's
like I think that's just human nature in
general it's like when someone isn't
feeling well or someone's you want
someone to nurture you or pay attention
and just help you and support you make
you feel comfortable and a lot of people
like I didn't get that as a kid sure I
just didn't get it I've I don't know if
I've talked about that necessarily but
you know
um
I I remember these things these are
vivid these aren't me making them up
they are they happened uh my parents
were never uh I remember opening the
garage door in I was probably 12 and
they had glass windows in it was old
rickety shitty garage door and it was
hard to open and I opened it and a piece
of glass fell and hit me in the mouth
okay and split my face open blood
everywhere okay and my dad just kind of
laughed and said go in and put ice on it
I go I'm I need to go to the hospital I
need to get stitches and he's like no
you don't
and I remember one time I many times
where I fireworks went off in my hand
these Spinners when I was a kid you know
the Spinners they got caught in my hand
and burned my hands badly and I was
screaming and agonizing pain in my put
your hand in cold water yeah and I
remember hours it just wouldn't go away
I slept with my hand in a pot of ice
water and this was sort of I remember I
didn't think about it then like oh
they're you know they're terrible there
but as you get older you're like no one
was there to sort of give you your
emotional needs like validate that hey
I'm in pain take care of me help me I'm
in pain help me take it and a lot of
people just don't really it's not that
they don't care that they just
I guess don't care and that's also you
know it's a different time right our
parents really didn't know no one knew
what they were doing I think now like
people like with parenting I have a
child so when you're saying this I'm
like yeah so when this happens like the
really the most important thing to me is
like meet my kids emotional needs make
sure that he knows like I'm there Mommy
loves him so he never has to waste any
time like earning love or getting love
he can just be his wonderful happy
independent self and Thrive and you know
validating his feelings it helps so much
like if he's how we like talk about the
feeling we name the feeling how old is
he he's three and so you can talk to him
like he he gets things he's smart he's
real smart and he's so wonderful and
he's happy and he's confident and he's
like he's telling me smart all the time
you're so smart I tell him how every day
and or I'll like tell him secrets I'll
go and Whisper to him like the other day
and I'll tell you Secrets yeah I'll just
whisper to him I said I just want to let
you know that I watched you like playing
with this kid earlier and it was so
awesome watching you learn and grow and
you're so smart and you're so funny and
you're so kind I whispered that to him
and he said thank you Mama
ah my kid is just delicious
can't Garden I can't I'm so lucky that's
just like wow I know
how important is that to to to children
to have parents who are I mean it's I've
talked about this so many times but like
just something a positive thing and and
to fill them with positive you know
Vibes and and you know they will get
more confident and smart and feel this
way because of you yeah because of their
mom yeah you know or dad and it's so
important
um having a kid is a big opportunity to
like heal your own [__] and do something
else to be a better person than maybe
your parents were totally and put a lot
of Consciousness into it and that's what
that's really what what I'm all about
with my kid so do you try to do things
because maybe your parents didn't give
you certain things as a kid so maybe
you're totally totally totally and who
knows like what who I'm trying to doing
my best to make sure that he just feels
happy and loved that's it and um but
yeah like just being conscious about
things so some you know you grow up and
you're like you know stop crying I'll
give you something to cry about then
you're like I cannot believe or like
your hands fine put it in ice like you
know let's acknowledge what's going on
and so the kid doesn't feel so spun yeah
I agree I agree I think I think maybe
that's why I haven't had children yet
yeah but when you do you'll have you'll
see it's an amazing opportunity to to
like put all of this stuff somewhere
it's pretty it's a great healing
opportunity it's a rebirth
yeah I guess this the fear is you know I
don't want to make the same mistakes I
don't and I know I won't because it's so
much because you're confident about it
you won't and you'll work at it you'll
go to therapy you'll like you know take
a real look at it yeah
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
do you go to therapy of course how long
have you been on a third bank I don't I
kind of go in and out of it yeah
um I'll kind of like tackle something
I'm a hardcore person you are you are
the music you listen to I'm ever being
on set with you yeah and you're just
listening to some like I don't want to
say avant-garde [__] but you're always
listening to some indie stuff you had an
indie band yeah you kind of like you're
sort of like you're a beautiful cell but
you're you have a Darkness to you for
sure you definitely have this darkness
and I want to know where that comes from
yeah I don't know it's just like what I
always gravitated when I was gravitude
you know when I when I was young I was
into that [__] and it just like
stuck I still like dress like when I was
a teenager what is that shirt this is
Johnny Cash yeah I thought it for a
second it was Journey but how dare you
were a journey shirt never you used to
make fun of my music I love your music
what are you talking about yeah I love
your music I love your big 80s rock
music oh good yeah I like that yeah
um
not to get too private but like growing
up how I was growing up but were your
parents like supportive and cool and
whatever listen when I was growing I'm
from a Farm in Pennsylvania and before
that I'm from an either even smaller
town and what I was doing chick skinny
Pennsylvania a really small town so what
I was doing was very foreign like nobody
really understood it I was scouted at
the mall when I was in 15 and started
modeling at 16. how does that happen you
are in the mall and somebody comes so
wait a minute you were in the mall
randomly yeah they were there or you
heard they were there and you went it's
honestly it's so long ago now that like
we were I just remember being like at
Payless shoe store or something like
that good and this woman came up to me
and was like oh you should have you ever
thought about modeling and my mom and I
were like what no how tall were you but
at the same time
skinny like you know I was five four
when I graduated high school no you
weren't oh yeah but it's not a small kid
in my high school but you're tall well
yeah that's probably why I had back
problems because I grew like nine inches
in the net in my car in college that's
funny but go ahead so you're like this
tall awkward kid yeah so I got like
plucked out of my town and started like
you know going to Manhattan by myself
and started traveling by myself and it
was just like your parents let you
travel by yourself I mean yeah that was
the time period wasn't it it was a
different time they just put you on a
train and you went yes as a 15 year old
girl you went to New York I went on a
bus because there was no train that went
to my small town but I went on a bus and
I did get picked up at Port Authority
and they thought I was a runaway
um yeah I don't what would they do they
detain you and like get people on the
phone and then they finally let you go
to your modeling job
how many times did it happen
um once or twice it just seems like it
wouldn't happen it happens yeah like
they would give a [__] it's crazy like
I'm so grateful for it because like it
made me grow up fast it made me Savvy it
made me take personal responsibility for
what I'm doing and it made me like
pretty Street Smart
um but now that I have a kid I'm like
Over My Dead Body yeah yeah right no
different world different world but
growing up you said hey you kind of like
validated or made it seem like it was a
good thing to grow up fast do you think
growing up fast is a good thing well I
think before that happened I really
wasn't sure what I was gonna do and I
think who does who does and I think that
that needs to be there needs to be some
attention on that because it's a
dangerous thing for kids to have this
much pressure on them to know what they
want to be when they grow up what school
they're going to go to for how like it's
so much so much pressure and I didn't
really know and we don't really know
that's that's a scary place to be so
when I finally like found the thing that
took some time I was like [__] yeah this
is what I'm doing were you smart in
school yeah enough yeah I was smart in
school I was like not a yeah I was kind
of like down the middle but you thought
this this is cool I'm gonna go model no
I did not think that was cool I was like
modeling and not sure but it was an
opportunity to get out of the house and
get out of my small town and it wasn't
until I was always kind of like big and
bubbly and obnoxious and annoying and
like funny were you really yeah I was
always liked class clownish a little bit
sometimes right um and
and so there was an actor strike at one
point in the agency I was with had an
acting Division and I was always walking
by the room like hey
so they were like oh would you like to
go out in commercial auditions um yes
thought you never ask so then I started
going to commercial auditions and that
was such a huge difference from modeling
when you're just like looking at your
book and oh your nose is too pointy oh
your butt's too big whatever
and this was an opportunity for me to be
funny and silly and goofy and they liked
that about me so I was like yes so most
models aren't silly and goofy that you
were around you were kind of a goofy one
uh-huh oh yeah they're not like that
models are like encouraged not to talk
now it's different I think like you have
to have like if you're a model you have
to have like some side hustle or
something else or something special
about it but at that time it was like
you know yeah just stand there and look
pretty like a clothing rack
and I the worst job for me let's just be
honest the worst job for me would be
like holding still and shutting up
yeah yeah well I think for me too yeah
yeah exactly but did you know was it
intimidating were other models sitting
around that were kind of like looking at
her like she's not pretty she's not
blonde she's not beautiful she's weird
people would always say that I wasn't
pretty people that was always wait who
would say that [__] come on I'm not
gonna like I'm not saying I'm proverbial
who yeah no who like like like like
adults kids you were picked on I I
wasn't that I was picked on but I was
like the other sort of thing you know I
wasn't like let's just be honest I'm not
like a blonde bombshell with like you
know I'm just just a different thing
you're a dark shell a dark bombshell
well you are gorgeous
um that's not fishing here I'm not
fishing I know you're not I'm I'm
casting okay
but that's how come I learned to be
funny there was this girl in in high
school named Heather Hart oh that's a
good name and she was super tall and
every guy was just sort of like two not
into it yeah because she was just this
tall girl and like she's like skinny
yeah she was doing like modeling stuff
and I remember it was like
but all of a sudden when she got older
like when she turned like 17 or whatever
I mean every guy in the world wanted her
so she was awkward growing up I think
she because she was just so tall and was
like oh my God the tall girl and
everybody else was shorter than her yeah
and then all of a sudden people realized
they don't realize the beauty that's
actually in front of them or the beauty
that's going to mature into real beauty
or whatever I think that you know look
you know
I was one of the least popular kids in
my school oh really I imagined you like
being like a football quarterback
hot babe no no okay now uh
yeah I wasn't and um but it's funny
because I think definitely people later
on couldn't believe that I went as far I
mean obviously they went as far as I did
I small town yeah like 3 000 people in
Newburgh Indiana yeah and uh you know so
same sort of thing but what happens when
hey where are your parents at now
they're still in my smoke they're still
they're in shitsville chicksville what
is it Pennsylvania they're in
Pennsylvania do you go back
um sometimes my dad actually just came
to visit me I've been I've been on
location for a couple of years like
non-stop now so my dad is um what are
you shooting
well I just finished something I just
got back Sunday I just finished Orphan
Black echoes in Toronto and then before
that I was doing
um Love and Death for HBO in Austin
which was dope
um so and before that I was in Oregon
I've just been like it's hard it's
better easier for people to come to you
sometimes at least right especially as a
child yes yeah yeah everything the
relocation is is just a whole other
thing now it's not just like me and my
like rocker t-shirts it's like a thing
well what do you do when you go back by
the way whenever it is you go back is it
is it something where people recognize
you
I mean yeah this is really small small
so everybody knows you no but it's not
like you're gonna see a lot of people
it's like the sticks you know but if I
went to like the market sure I'd
probably run into somebody I went to
high school with yeah what's the local
place where everybody goes what's it
called I honestly I don't know but I
there's like a the one market you would
go and like get stuff it's like Sun Ray
Market I would go there after school hey
sure yeah yeah do you like do you like
when people come up to you and ask you
for pictures autographs or are you just
uncomfortable because that's how do you
feel I usually I like it usually I'm so
grateful to have like anybody even see
what I do or have an impact on people
um it depends like some people are
really cool about it and some people
aren't that cool about it like it just
depends on what's happening what's the
situation you remember that somebody was
just not cool you know when someone's
like
uh what hey that person said you're
somebody what are you in I've never
heard anything yeah that you don't need
to bother somebody with that that's okay
that is one thing that pisses me that's
the one thing I've I I think did I tell
you about that I was in a I was in
um some bar mistake years ago and I was
with a couple friends and this drunk
dude yeah comes up to me and goes hey I
I don't even know who you are but like
you're are you like I don't care like
but my friend said you're like why throw
that bomb into somebody's life like why
why ruin your night you're having fun
why give that like you know what I mean
like and the thing is I want to look at
them and go [__] oh yeah I know but you
can't and you can't and you're just like
hey yeah no I'm just whatever it doesn't
matter I'm no big deal yeah I don't care
and they're like you just want to say
dude you drunk [__] leave me alone yeah
you got to be nice yeah yeah typically
though typically because like
um you know I've I've sort of played
characters and that have meant a lot to
women yes and specifically Jessica Jones
so I get a certain kind of person who
wants to connect and I I love that
because it's one thing to like just do
an acting job great love it but it's
another thing it's kind of so meaningful
when you play a character that really
resonates with women and and and Men you
know the way that she has so I'm always
thrilled when people
um appreciate the work obviously anytime
someone comes up to you and says they
love your work you're like [__] thank
you thank you so much obviously so I'm
happy to do it unless I'm like with my
little baby and like of course okay just
not right now is not a good time yeah
and you have to hold that boundary too
because I don't want my child
he is number one
um but when I'm like out and about by
myself sure come up I'll [__] take a
selfie right let's rock let's do it yeah
do your are your parents really proud of
you yeah yeah I think people are pretty
pretty shocked by it you know yeah like
does your mom still like every time you
do something go
do they watch it all or some like I
don't know if they watch Jessica Jones
is really dark my dad wouldn't watch
that no and you warned him I'm having
sex in the first episode I didn't even I
I just knew it wasn't right sure so you
chose not to watch it it was okay that
they didn't watch it I just whatever if
they watch it cool but yeah I mean
yesterday my mom texted me I guess Brian
Cranston was just on Kelly Clarkson this
week like talking about the big like
death scene with me and they're sending
it to me I'm like all right cool yeah so
really yeah do you so do you still talk
to Aaron and Brian yeah I just saw Aaron
at a karaoke party
he's such a nice guy he was nervous
about karaokeing oh God and then he
ended up doing it it was really great he
was great yeah but what was that
experience I mean you were on how many
episodes
don't know not many not many I was in
the second season maybe like Eight
Episodes I don't know uh so then that's
a lot one episode The Following season
and how many episodes did you think you
were going to be on when you first got
the part like five I ended up being in
it more than I thought
and was it something that you it was
already hit by this point it wasn't a
hit it wasn't a hit at this point it
wasn't even like on the radar yet when I
took the gig it was only a one season
seven episode show because of the
writer's strike so it was a big down and
down time in the industry it was all
slow
um I really liked the part and I wanted
to get it and my agent at the time he
was really good and really smart his
name was David Letterman I was at with a
d Letterman with a d i was an Innovative
artist I had another offer for something
else that was more of like what I was
doing what I was doing and he was like
let's hang on and let's see what happens
with breaking bad because no one knows
about the show yet but it's but it's
really good and I think you could be
really cool in this role so we held we
waited until I until that happened and
you were so happy you got that [__] yeah
because it was more like it was like you
know I I just felt like it was more in
my like real house yeah yeah yeah
because before that I was just doing a
lot of like goofy ditzy kind of Comedy
roles which are fun too but you know it
was Vince on set yeah Vince was on set
or he was like you know what was really
cool about him and those kind of show
Runners Melissa Rosenberg is similar
very detail-oriented and I think that is
like the key I think when you have
someone with such a true Clear Vision
that's why you get some magic
yeah when you say
detailed like we're talking yeah was
Vince directing that episode no he
directed El Camino right um but but that
episode or a few of the episodes that
you did he didn't direct but he was
there and he's sort of like almost like
Spielberg Toby Hooper and Poltergeist
where toh Hooper was directing it but
did Spielberg direct it well it's just
kind of the thing like for just for one
stupid example like the character is
wearing a belt they take pictures of
both belts and it goes to Vince Vince is
going to choose the you know what I mean
yes yes all little things like
everything mattered to him which I think
is very cool
um and Melissa Rosenberg has a similar
style and it doesn't that doesn't always
happen with showrunners right it's like
a free-for-all
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh
do those thoughts keep you from showing
care when it counts new and improved
Dove men plus care antiperspirant with
72 hours sweat and odor protection and
one quarter moisturizing cream helps you
forget about your underarms so you can
be present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant or ever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
were you surprised
of course you're surprised but after
your character dies yeah if you haven't
seen the show I'm tough [__] I'm sorry
um what was it 2012 I don't know yeah
whatever
um when this you look you shot it it was
hard it was probably intense yeah you
know it's so
fuffed up yeah
did you ever think that that scene would
be a tenth as big as what it became no
[__] idea no way no I didn't know any
of it when you saw it before it all came
out and everybody else commented were
you like people are gonna be talking
about this one well we started to so
that was the big episode that I was in
and my character had a lot to do and
they started the network started to sort
of talk about the performance and like
it was the people were getting excited
about it so we were invited
to watch it
in a room it was me my managers my agent
at the time is Brent Morley I'll never
forget it and we watched it
and all of us
were on our feet like hands over mouths
[__] energy like we were shocked
we were just shocked and so moved by it
and that was like the coolest [__]
thing I had ever done
I was like they brought your own perform
not your but the experience the
experience brought you to your feet I
first my agent stood at his feet and
I'll I just felt him like stand up like
and then kind of all of us and I'm kind
of you know when you watch yourself you
have a different experience of it
because I'm like oh when that in this
moment what was actually happening was
this so you're watching it but then you
kind of are able to just like sit back
and enjoy it too I was just so proud to
be like in something cool right it
doesn't always happen I know it never
really happened never happens never
happens and there's so many people out
there so many actors direct whatever
that they are capable of doing something
but the things that happen Perfect Storm
of it being a great show all eyes are on
it the right director the right Creator
the right props the right ones whatever
the DP the everything comes together to
make this moment and it's never happened
I hate to say it but there's a lot of
not obviously skill but luck yes there's
a lot of luck for all these things to
come together yeah a lot of skilled
people but for that to all come together
that is just it's it's miraculous it's
one of the best
let alone TV film it whatever it is
um it's crazy I can't I mean it's still
like it's crazy I feel so lucky to have
been a part of something so amazing and
so well done and like they caught
lightning in a bottle did you continue
to watch that show when you were [__]
yeah I'll watch it again I might like
fast forward my scenes a little bit
you know because I'm like oh yeah what
am I doing idiot young and
um but I love the show I I mean yeah I
love it I feel like I could probably
start watching it again tomorrow I need
a show to watch maybe I'll watch
Breaking Bad I think the my favorite
shows of all time are Breaking Bad Game
of Thrones Game of Thrones
um
Breaking Bad Game of Thrones those are
the two best shows I think that's it
Sopranos is pretty great I haven't I've
only done one season sure it's it's
pretty great but it didn't hook you in
that way
yeah I'll give it I'm gonna continue to
watch him but is there anything else I'm
missing there's some great shows and
people listening what I got this and
what about that they'll be chiming in
let's get the timing I'd say Breaking
Bad in Game of Thrones are my two
favorite shows and then I also like on
the Lighter Side friends and Sex in the
City that's right yeah yeah yeah but I'm
a girl those are sure sure no I'm not
saying they're bad they're obviously
great shows to many people yeah
I love them yeah I'm sure they're great
they're obviously great look at the
success although there's a lot of shows
that are successful during great shows
that's true very a lot of shows it's
weird yeah gosh did uh this this
obviously that role would you say
launched your career 100 that little
that role I want to say little but that
significant role yeah on that show yeah
launched your career and you probably
didn't get paid a lot I didn't get paid
a lot at all let's just put it that way
I mean but it was worth every moment it
was worth every it was worth it it
wasn't that wasn't for the money and
Netflix fell in love with you we got to
find a show for this girl yes no I don't
know uh hands Jessica Jones yeah Jessica
Jones yeah which happened how many years
after
well at first I did the b in apartment
23. yes that lasted a couple Seasons yep
two seasons you love that show I do I
would do it again in a second Why didn't
it get picked up why it was a listen it
was on ABC it was right before things
the metrics sort of changed like we got
canceled for numbers that now are
considered like massive hits right
um it was kind of like scheduled badly
it just was kind of dragged around by a
[__] smeared dog didn't really but it
was also very edgy and we really pushed
the envelope the writing was way ahead
of its time and it was just one of those
like great little quirky shows that
probably probably served everybody
better by just being two seasons yeah
because it's like you know cult
following people love it I love it I
will watch it and laugh at every line
because the writing is so good do you
get upset how do you deal with
um cancellations or rejection I mean
obviously you start at a young age with
rejection everywhere it's just part of
it so when they said who called you to
tell you apartment uh yeah the [__]
from apartment 23. yeah that that was
the ACT that was the hardest rejection
that whatever it's all in the camera
because you were surprised I was
surprised but I also loved it so much
and I know yes I cried but I would cry
before that there were days driving home
from set where I just had the best day
and I would go home I would drive home
crying knowing it'll never be as good as
this again
I had the best day The Producers on that
show let me tell you Jeff Morton he is
he's a producer for Modern Family he's
done like all heat part of his whole
system is like let's make sure the cast
and the crew are rested and happy so
they could be funny who is that who is
that no one thinks that no one thinks
that and he is so special and I I would
I want to do another show with him so
badly because he cares about people I
want to work with Jeff Morton Jeff
Martin Jeff Martin Jeff Martin Jeff
I'll auditioned for you on tape he just
cared about that and we would shoot like
10 hour days
what comedies comedies and you know what
oh my God I felt so supported so
supported to like be able to push myself
even further so I all I was trying to do
all day was like get learn my funny
lines and how do I make them even
funnier how do I improvise this thing
how do I do this little weird character
thing because I was so supported that I
was able to be like free to [__] play
see this is an important thing you're
saying most
creators most
Studios whoever is involved in all this
process of making a show they don't
realize that and this goes not for just
acting World it goes to the entire
planet of people bosses out there
corporations if you treat the people yes
well if you support them you'll get
better and more you'll not only get
better performances and more passion and
more Dr it's just going to be a better
Show everybody's going to be happier
more joy and they don't they always 90
of the time they want to show how
powerful they are I'm not going to do
that I'm not going to give you the money
you deserve I'm not going to give you
the hours you're going to work overtime
we're going to force you we're changing
this who cares you're not even on they
don't care no and that is really
refreshing to hear that someone was that
guy he was that guy he was that guy and
it was such a magical experience but
that was after Breaking Bad so that was
kind of like did the Breaking Bad Thing
and
at that before that I was like working
actress hustling just you know whatever
and then that was when I started to like
get offered things and Don't Trust the B
was next and I just [__] loved it and
Jessica Jones was there something you
auditioned for Jessica Jones was
something I auditioned for with like
fake sides and I was like the material
was fabulous it was so loaded there was
so much subtext there was so much to
play and so much to do how long did it
take you to learn these lines for an
audition oh that takes me no time no
time no time but I but it's the work I I
do like listen I work really hard before
the day and then to get rid of it and so
when I just try to know things so well
that you throw a grenade at me I know
how to handle it or that way if you're
so prepared you know your lines I can
memorize lines really quickly it's the
subtext and the performance underneath
like that's where I spend most you could
learn five pages of dialogue right now
in the next 30 minutes listen I hate to
be an [__] but yes I can but that's
not what it's about no it is no it's not
I mean a lot of it is the subtext is is
where the work goes no I know what
you're saying I'm saying though if I
could learn five pages of dialogue in a
half an hour yeah
my life would be exponentially better
sure uh it takes me a while to learn
them and but I do what you do is I learn
it inside out so if they throw a grenade
at me and let me ask you have has
something happened or did something
happen in your past that caused you to
have the deepest preparation because
maybe you weren't prepared early on in
your career and something happened and
they threw a curveball at you and you
didn't handle it as well as you thought
um no I I think that just because so
when I was modeling I would kind of
notice that
um you know models would get set home
after two seasons that they didn't hit
so I have this like observation early
like you get one [__] shot
so success isn't the only [__]
option right so I just had that in me
for a long time and I always I never I
always could put my head on the pillow
knowing if I worked really hard and I
prepared and I was ready if I didn't get
the part that's okay
that was always okay so for me my
superpower was like working hard
discipline discipline working hard I'm
always I can show up five minutes
earlier than you you might be a better
actor than me but I'm gonna like work
work harder than you that was kind of
like I just that was the thing that was
what made me feel like I had control
over my career in my life
working hard D I love that that's it it
was just like how do I feel good about
like I would never want to like go to an
audition and like kind of blow it
because I didn't work hard on it
if I didn't get it okay that's fine
there's no there's only one no no you're
not gonna get everything so there's some
very specific thing for every part you
are going to hear no 99 times in a row
but if I go in and like do my thing and
worked hard at it and do my play and
that's it go home and I had my fun how
do you I love this this is this makes
perfect sense uh I love it uh how do you
yeah okay good
I love this this is just like
rapid fire I mean it's just like I'm
just I'm feeling the the back and forth
how do you deal with an actor that isn't
hang on
we all deal with it it's hard I'm sure
other actors have dealt with me
how do you deal with someone giving them
respect making them feel like you like
them making you feel like you like them
as an actor and not letting them all
know that you think they are not good
because they're not good and you're
performing with them does that make
sense okay I thought you were gonna ask
like how do you work with an actor who
doesn't prepare and doesn't work hard
and doesn't like do the things well both
that's hard for that's hard that's
challenging it's disappointing when you
have have you ever said anything no you
know I I try to like lift the people up
and like oh do you want to run this do
you want to you know
try to make it as good as possible
but you know I've been pretty lucky I've
had some amazing scene Partners who do
work hard and that's the most exciting
part if you get a great scene partner
it's a great game of tennis as you know
and you're only as good as your scene
partner is I've been really lucky I've
gotten some I've gotten to work with
some great people who then like make you
better and you're like oh what are you
doing with that oh like I just worked
with an actor the other day on set
um uh I I guess I won't say who it is
but I
he was so good
that I in rehearsal
I was so like caught up and I was
watching him like kind of missing my
cues which was so exciting because I was
just like oh what the [__] did you tell
him I did and I we have we actually have
the same acting teacher so I told her
afterwards which like he's really good
really good and I gotta say it happened
with David Tennant too ah David Tennant
from um uh on Jessica Jones yeah Jessica
Jones and then Defenders yes right he
wasn't in Defenders but he was in
Jessica Jones and there was one day it's
a villain he's the villain
and there were some scenes where I would
where I was just watching him because
that was like the dynamic there were
some days where I would just watch him
and be like this guy is [__] Jazz
just he's doing this and then he's doing
this and it just he he's that good so
good so good those are the people we
want to work with was it intimidating or
exciting it's exciting it's exciting
I I love it it's just rare it's rare
yeah it's rare I can't say that uh
there have been many where I'm like
enamored or oh my God yeah this is I'm
working with greatness I've got to step
up it's happened yeah but it hasn't
happened a ton of times yeah usually
it's like all right let's just make this
as good as we can make this sure you
know what I mean yeah not ever not not
all of them are going to be home runs
right not everything they do aren't home
right and like most scenes like you know
the best thing about acting I mean what
I love about it is like when you're so
in a scene that you like are so in it
and you disappear and you don't know
where you stop and the character starts
it's like that moment where you are
truly present it's like that it's like
jumping waves it's like that namaste in
[__] yoga at the end it's those kind
of things where you are so present
everything else just goes away and
that's not gonna happen in every single
scene yeah and sometimes it won't happen
for a year sometimes it won't happen an
entire project sometimes but when it
does
is there one thing that comes to you
that is probably at look let's just say
there are tons of great scenes that
you've done yeah Great Moments great
actors but is there one that stands out
in your career so thus far that you go
I just remember this day being the most
special in terms of like electric and
the feeling of acting and the feeling of
being in it and just and and the way it
turned out or maybe not the way it
turned out but how it felt yeah I mean
the show that I just finished I
definitely had a lot of opportunities to
to act
and go there and like was like [__] yeah
that was we really did it but um I don't
know I haven't seen it yet so we don't
know that one the feeling I did have the
feeling a handful of times on this one
which is great but I have and I had it a
lot on Jessica Jones as well because I
got to do that kind of writing
it's not all Exposition it is all coming
from a place of character truth it's a
psychological character study so anytime
you get like that juicy backstory and
underbelly of the character like that's
when you have the opportunities to do
that you don't know not all characters
are gonna like you know yeah reach the
depths of of whatever Who You Are
um and that's okay it's also fun to just
just hit your mark and say some lines
yeah that's also very fun
um but yeah I would say and Jessica
Jones there was just so many how many
episodes did you do in the first season
um 13. 13. you're the lead role it's
called Jessica Jones yeah hence
um
how soon before you get all the scripts
or are they coming to you as the show is
continuing on that one
um they were coming as the show was
continuing they had written the first
four episodes I believe before I was
cast or maybe the first three
but I do I remember then getting the
script
that they had written after I was cast
and you could tell
I was like oh wow they're writing for me
now the question is you talk about
memorizing your lines really fast that's
easy but when you're working and I I
guarantee you're working 12 to 14 hour
days minimum oh my God minimum plus hair
and makeup and travel time so how by
being in the moment Yeah by acting out
these scenes hair and makeup take after
take
all the [__] on your feet all day how
and when do you have time to learn the
next script which is the following week
here's what I do
um I just said this before Orphan Black
and I did it with Jessica Jones I so
with Jessica Jones I the first four
Scripts
so I will Coach with my acting teacher
Marjorie Valentine every single day
every single day every single day every
single day before I leave before I go
before you go and do every we'll do each
script we'll start back at the beginning
well as much material as I can get in
advance and then I sit with it I work on
the subtext we kind of go through it we
like subtext every line we talk about it
we try to she's expensive yeah but
that's okay
I mean this is inexpensive you're not
talking like an hour acting class yeah I
know you dissect scripts oh yes my
scripts look like a murder scene they
are covered in ink
there's not a no white is left by that
no line is Right circles on my lines
yeah and a couple of little things yes
yeah sure just notes of like different
ways to do things or try things next
time you have a next time you get an
opportunity go coach with Marjorie See
it'll bring out a whole lot here's the
thing even oh I will even even roles
where I'm like this is my bread and
butter this is what I can do in my sleep
I don't need to coach I'll coach with
her she will always find something
because two heads are better than one
it's just a support it's support
okay continue so you're working on these
scenes I work on it exhausted and I
finish it and basically could then set
it on fire and then I will not even look
at the schedule I won't look at anything
oh this is what we're doing today got it
for the first four episodes yes unless
something changes unless any changes and
then on Orphan Black The Orphan Black
Echoes I had the first
um five or six
so then that's a long time but what
happens when the fourth episode's over
and you're now doing the fifth and
there's no Marjorie well because I have
done so much work that this character is
now in me I will know how to do it
I will know how to handle it that's kind
of like what the process is for me and
so do you pick up a script while you're
shooting Yeah well yeah I'll when the
script comes out I'll read it and kind
of just like bring it a little bit yes
exactly you'll just start bit by bit
learning it yeah and it's about 40 or 50
pages yeah
yep and by the time you're shooting it
you're ready to go I'm ready but you
don't memorize the scene the night
before
um if I don't know it I will ask
sometimes like if we're really in the
machine of it and I'm like oh where are
we I would I ask for my scenes for the
next day to be printed at lunch
so if there I can get a refresher I'm
like oh right right and go back to my
notes whatever I need to do like so I'm
ready so you usually rely on the
director and sort of the creator of a
project if by chance you get the this
Pages the night before and you've kind
of learned them you know them but you're
like oh I haven't had as much time as I
usually like to prep on a scene and work
it out that I'll I'll work it out I
trust the process that in the scene I'll
find it it depends on the context like
if it's a real scene no real scenes like
I will do all the things but if it's a
thing we're like oh we're gonna like
walk down a hallway and like get a
couple of months then yeah I'm like okay
hopefully the director has a great shape
in mind already
gotcha yeah but if it's like a real
scene I'm gonna come in with ideas as
well right or like oh I saw it like this
how can we figure it out because you
always you know it's hard it gets harder
now too with like such time constraints
like on rehearsals it's like hurry up
and throw marks down where it should be
let's like make sure we're actually
filming something that's worth filming
yes and you know what you said something
there have you ever had where they're
trying to rush yeah and we gotta get
done with the day I remember you and I
okay me and you whatever I'm not great
in grammar we were shooting that pilot
that never did anything and we're
sitting in a car and they're really
stressed yeah and it's outside and
they're like all right and I do you
remember me just going or maybe it was
you
one of us go guys hey
let's we got to get this performance and
we got to get something like relax here
we got to get this we can't just rush
through it it's making everybody
stressed out yeah do you remember that I
don't remember I do remember that and
everybody was kind of like oh yeah take
a beat yeah yeah let's just do what we
have to do here yeah have you ever had
to do that
um I think you know once in a blue moon
if you can't like figure out a scene if
you can't block it it's if it's
something's not working we gotta take a
second we gotta like see where the issue
is how can we fix it and let's fix it
let's make it let's all make the best
thing that we can possibly make yeah um
so sometimes that comes up and that's
just part of it
um yeah but ideally
um what I try to do is when I like get
the scripts if I'm like if anything
feels eggy or if I'm like this I know
isn't gonna work because I know how it
all goes I'll talk to talk to the writer
in advance
have a call send her an email yeah let's
address this first so we don't have egg
on our face on the day so we don't waste
Productions time do you ever think uh
I don't know what that's gonna look like
I don't know if we got that but anyway
moving on
uh yeah sure like when you do it like
think about you're doing like a hundred
scenes like not all of them Daredevil
uh did not goes back as Kingpin
I worked with D'Onofrio amazing guy any
chance you'll be back as Jessica Jones I
have no idea I hope so you really don't
have no idea but I hope so I hope so I
think that people love people love
Jessica I know because I live it and so
do you think there's a good chance I
honestly I don't know and like Marvel
doesn't if they're so secretive I don't
know
um I'm just putting out there that of
course I would be there in a second I
got I'd have my boots and jacket on
ready to rock speaking of that you you
kind of did you create the look yes and
I ruined it for myself because it
created a whole look for people I know
and I'm like [__] I can't wear my
regular clothes anymore it's a leather
jacket look yeah yeah I loved yeah she
looked so [__] cool yeah I think you
have a lot to do with almost every time
I think the actor should yes but you
like even for Night books working with
our lovely Autumn who I adore and so
hugely talented but like you worked very
close with her to get that look of what
you both wanted yeah envisioned it is
very I am very very collaborative and
very Hands-On with the costume designer
always because
you know I sort of always start my
characters at home with like a
physicality or a walk and then like it's
the clothes it's the all of that creates
the character it's not like here now
you're gonna wear this it's like a real
creation from the ground up and I
breathe all that life into it and I need
that and so yeah the costume on Jessica
Jones for sure like that I spent [__]
little all of it
um again quickly David Tennant
um I know he's a genius he's a great
actor everybody loves him that there's
such a sensation for Doctor Who I've
never seen Doctor Who Have you seen it
um no but my let me tell you something
there is and I've seen it because I've
traveled with him holy [__] and also
when when my manager Kyle I don't know
if you've ever met him but my manager
Kyle found out that David Tennant was
getting the role we're sitting in the
director's office S.J Clarkson Jessica
Jones looking at the mood boards and the
shot lists and all of that and like oh
who's gonna play kilgrave and she told
us and Kyle made sounds that I have
never heard him make before because he
is such a doctor who fan he was like
more excited that David Tennant was
going to be in the show than when I got
the role
um and then going to Comic-Con with him
and traveling with him he's like he's
the favorite doctor people love David
Tanner and it's rightfully so because
the guy not only not only is an amazing
heavyweight actor he's so lovely and so
delicious and just like so fun I just
adore him is he in England
yeah he's Scottish but he's probably I
don't know where he is where's Scottish
yeah great Scottish accent think about
your Apple
fast
tear you know what this gets a square I
always finish my jobs faster you do
don't you yeah well no I'm not saying
it's just like it could be any time but
I don't I don't do more than an hour I
just don't like it I just don't I mean
we've talked about great stuff this is
great so you got Orphan Black the sequel
car from black Echoes Echoes coming out
how many episodes that's 10 episodes 10
episodes on AMC on AMC yep
um and Love and Death on HBO
and you delete a map no I'm not the lead
in that I'm the lead of orpha black
echoes I'm not the lead in Love and
Death what was the hardest series you've
worked on Jessica Jones yeah yeah that
was pretty hard but in a good way I I'm
not I'm on all good things about that
one
that was so fun do you sleep well [__]
no do you no no I do not sleep well how
do you do it then you know what I just
keep rocking I just keep just [__]
power through I don't know how old are
you how old are you I'm 50. I am not 50.
you're like 36 or something sure well it
says on the line doesn't it yeah but who
cares I'm just saying how do you not how
do you never ask a woman age yeah the
only reason I said that is because how
do you not sleep and able to just keep
rocking and rolling I don't know I have
I don't know if you don't have any bags
under your eyes I should because I
haven't slept and you have a child yeah
and you can do Lead Series so you're
doing leads lead roles you're taking
care of being the best mom whispering in
here in his ear how awesome he is and
how proud of you and a child and the
lead role and looking great and not
sleeping it's an anomaly you're an alien
I am tired I'm not gonna lie I'm very
tired I don't know I just keep [__]
going
like a shark and the Defenders you love
doing the Defenders that was so fun
because it's all the superheroes with
like a lighter schedule
and they're doing a lot of stunts so
we're all sitting around just like
shooting the [__] we had so much fun it
was like Ming it was so fun because I
love Charlie Cox so much and I love Mike
Coulter so much and Finn was having like
we just had the best time just laughing
all day what's your favorite movie of
all time yep [__] first thing that comes
to mind is the lost boys but there's so
many more agree started dancing I had
Kiefer and Jason Patrick on podcast
Pitter Patter Pitter Patter they were
awesome
I asked them about Julia Roberts and you
know the whole thing yeah the Scandal
yeah what happened what do you say they
answered it they were just like I go
Kiefer you know he took off with your
ex-fiance that you're about to get
married to to Italy and is your best
friend and how did you ever how are you
guys sitting here right now he's like
yeah well you know we're friends man and
time and you know it's it's my buddy I'm
like
all right no he was cool about it you
know what that's why I liked um David's
movie night book so much I love Night
books I love Night books I went to the
screening it was cold at the screen it
was outside I froze my balls off yeah
but I'm glad I was there and it was
great it was such an adventure and I
think he did such a great job on him
such a great job you were great in that
night books on Netflix guys I loved it I
had such a good time doing that show it
was my first gig back after having my
son they look they adored you I don't
know anybody who doesn't like working
with you I like to be at work so it's
that's that's fun and infectious some
you know I've only been on like one set
that was like really miserable but most
of the time I try and like you know
rally and try to like have a good time
you're easy going I try to be but it's
because I work hard and I'm confident in
it
you know my my brother and I always talk
about my father you know he was he was
tough he was tough on us and like many
fathers can be I guess but we always
said that he he loved his the people he
worked with more sure we always said
that the people at work he treated the
best that he loved the most he loved
being around the most that was his world
uh-huh what did he do he worked in
Pharmaceuticals okay they didn't take
them but uh you know yeah so I guess I'm
trying to the analogy is like is work
what you love the most yeah I work as
well and the real life is kind of like
your real life is work almost yeah you
know the work is your life when you do
that kind of when you love your work
like that it's it's a rarity it's such a
big full immersive experience that it is
your life and um yeah it is your life do
you remember doing Gilmore Girls did you
like it totally you did yeah it was one
of my first gigs yeah I was basically
paying to be on that show really yeah
because I auditioned for it when I was
like in LA one day but I was a New York
actress and then it shot in San Diego so
I'm like getting myself to San Diego
for like a day rate somebody said that
this could be hearsay it's probably not
even true I don't even know but that
somebody said that the girls didn't get
along really well I was only on the last
season so I did not see that I didn't
see a lot of the ships
I don't know anything I didn't
experience that at all I had a good time
there and I was a weird little gig
because I was barely in it but it got a
lot of attention and that is a show that
people love and stands the test of time
and
um it was just like one of my cute like
early gigs
I like it
um all right this is a rapid fire with
patrons they're gonna you just answer
fast sure
top tier patrons asking questions go to
patreon.com inside of you thank you here
we go the last two episodes I don't know
when they're gonna air but I didn't ask
questions because it was just too
involved uh Stone Age who made you laugh
the most on the set while filming She's
Out of My League one of my favorite
movies uh TJ Miller
he was very funny everyone you know who
else
um Nate Torrance really oh my God he was
so funny Jay Baruchel is pretty funny
too it was really oh and Jeff stultz was
in it too and I agree they all made you
laugh they all made me laugh and Alice
Eve and I had so much fun it was like
the most fun it was so we were all 26
years old we were all staying in a hotel
in Pittsburgh getting into trouble we
had the best time
Nico any plans for your novel before uh
bonfire to get made into a film yeah so
it's a long process and it hasn't
happened yet it was optioned and sort of
we'll see I hope so I am working on
another follow-up to it which will be
announced shortly really I am what's
bonfire about bonfire is
um a psychological Thriller
would you play the lead well I might be
getting too old to play it now now next
one I'm gonna make sure the characters
still play in your late 20s thank you
especially if you sleep yeah yeah thank
you Nathan Jay I'm so excited for Orphan
Black spin-off are you playing multiple
characters too is it connected to the
original it is not really connected to
the original but it is tangential to the
original
um uh it's set in that world so I think
fans of the original are going to be
like into it but it's not like you have
to watch it to to step in
um I can't say much more beyond that at
this point even though like I know when
it's coming out is it dark
um it is it's pretty [__] it's cool
it's like it's pretty yeah it's dark and
cool and edgy in rock and roll and
science fiction and [__] yeah it's
cool all right Raj what is your most
prized possession besides your little
boy besides my little boy I love my um
Gibson Hummingbird do you play guitar a
lot yeah I have a beautiful guitar
I also
um I I really like my car I really like
um uh you do like your car you thought
you dented it at my house I know but
Well we I'm not gonna mention your car
yeah I do I like my car because it's
like where now as a mom that's where I
go to like blast my music really loud
and like have quiet alone time it's like
my office
I'm gonna make calls when going to the
car
I love her I love you Leanne don't trust
the bee in apartment 23 is one of my
all-time favorite shows what's your
favorite moment from that show I my
favorite moment from Don't Trust the B
is the episode where called sexy people
where Chloe takes over People magazine
never have I had more fun since then
even just the most delicious it was a
psychotic character playing a character
who do you want to work with like what's
the the top five people you could come
to mind that you're like I want to work
with this person I've always watched
them I've always uh oh my God I don't
even know where to start like I you know
you want to work with like people who
are really like have a lot of pride in
their work and are really fun and people
that Meryl Streep yes Gary Oldman
everybody yes I would love to work with
Meryl Streep and Gary Oldman of course
every all of them everyone that's on
your list I would like to work with them
too what's the biggest director you've
worked with
Tim Burton
what was with Tim Burton uh big eyes oh
my God yeah whatever yeah I would love
to work with him again in a in another
capacity in any way yeah the guys
created Smallville Alan miles created
Wednesday I'll get the [__] out I don't
know why you're not on there as some
kind of cool character just put me in
the background I'm gonna tell them tell
them put me in the background no you
could be like her her Aunt I should
totally she's like 20. you could be your
aunt yeah I should be like the the
grown-up one or whatever can you totally
see that please call them if they have a
spin-off called Wednesday 10 years later
you [__] call them right now and you
tell them I'm available hold on watch
this and I will hang on hang on I'm
there it would be like you know okay so
can I tell you one story when I was 12
years old I got I started a new school
12 years old 13 going into seventh grade
right new school I'll have to walk to
the bus station I've got my like long
black hair My Guns and Roses shirt
whatever I get on the bus these kids
have never met me before and they're
singing
the [__] kids were singing but
I could totally see that yeah I know now
it makes sense but at the time it was
pretty crushing oh he's in the zoom room
with probably Tim Burton right now you
tell him and I just said on with Kristen
Ritter hop on if you can
because I will tell him live on the
podcast dude you plea you make this
happen for me and I'm gonna buy you a
steak dinner I would do it your friend I
would do it anyway I'm going to do it
okay fine I wish more people would do
that for me no one does that this has
been too fun isn't it yeah this is fan
this is fantastic I'm not kidding I
thought this is gonna be good she's cool
she's you you just
you just you're a spark I love it I love
talking to you it's great me too I had
so much fun I hope it's not I hope
people like your podcast and I don't
think it's this is a boring episode why
would this be boring I don't know and
you see how we you know we ended up we
end up talking about the one thing we
didn't talk about is like something
she's eating an apple Let It Go
um oh great that's probably annoying no
it's not I'll move my head away yeah but
you talk a little bit about you know the
anxiety that you get is usually when you
have to do press and all those things
yes but I find a way to use it ages ago
I heard a TED talk about how to like use
your nervousness as like your superpower
and I tried to reframe how I thought
about it and and then that whole thing
was like okay what's the worst that's
gonna happen
are you gonna throw up you're gonna
faint so what
and that really helped me kind of get
through it like right who cares if I
throw up it's embarrassing embarrassing
people are going to talk about it
whatever so you really don't deal with a
lot of anxiety throughout life in in
mostly sometimes I do it depends on
what's going on like sometimes I
absolutely do and anxiety I mean like
the body you're tingling you're like I
don't know what to do absolutely I have
had periods of like intense intense
anxiety and it's like you know the
weight of the world or whatever it's
like shit's going on you're not sleeping
like all of that stuff
um compounding I'll get some anxiety for
sure
and it'll manifest in physical but you
never got on any meds or any exams or
anything no no you've never no but I
tackle it
I tackle it like with
whatever all the things that you do like
meditation exercise meditation exercise
nutrient dense food juices like do just
do whatever you can to fill up your your
cup that's it
that's I try and so when I get to it
like oh I'm in rough shape right now
what can I do okay let's meet let's
reach out to friends let's see a
therapist let's go work out book the
trainer I asked my trainer I'm like what
days do you have available copy
confirmed I'll be there just say yes I
think is huge eat well I mean sometimes
my diet's not great I love like pizza
and pasta and hamburgers but I love like
hobbies and so I'll throw myself into a
hobby whatever are you athletic
um what do you think
I'm not going to answer that I'm pretty
tall and gangly so I'm like sports how
tall are you five nine you're still five
nine since you were 15 you're five nine
I might be a little hair more five nine
and a half yeah
interesting
well that's very informative why what
that I'm just I'm still five nine no
just the whole anxiety thing yeah yeah
yeah no it's good it's very good it's
very good so yeah I have anxiety I use
it when I can I try to use the nervous
energy I try to use it and just like
reframe how I stress out about it
whenever possible I'm not an expert but
I do like try my best and I do like keep
going are you really good at comforting
people making people feel okay yes
absolutely I'm a yes I'm a good friend
do you follow your own advice yes and
sometimes like I don't I try to like not
always give advice you know you want to
like hold space and acknowledge and
validate and I kind of do those things
because like that's what I want too yeah
how do you help people that don't want
to help themselves
um I don't I if people don't want to
help help themselves I don't really have
a lot of those kinds of kinds of things
but um listen I like I'm a person who
likes to go deep and communicate and
like have emotional connections and like
really talk about what's going on like
get really in the room and so yeah I
think I'm I'm a good friend because
[__] like let's talk about it here it
is Kristen Ritter this has been awesome
uh you can finish your Apple and uh I
have a salad in the fridge don't take
that with you or eat it whatever it's
hungry it's good yeah I do because I am
busy and like I do really I really
appreciate when people give me food
well because I have a kid too yeah you
know what I mean so there's no one I'm
like a mom I'm a run I'm on the run I'm
working I'm taking care of a kid when
somebody offers me food you take it or
says like oh that must be really hard
I'm like oh like this that literally you
probably haven't ate anything but this
juice here today uh this is my I've
eaten the apple and the juice that's it
today so you're probably hungry yeah all
right yeah good talking to you okay
I loved it I loved it
love you Kristen it was a joy you're a
joy to have on very animated and very
smart
um great stories and uh just open you
know I like the openness right yeah you
know she was fun were you here for her I
was here you were here yeah she's she's
great she's really great you know she's
really easy to talk to mm-hmm
she was
uh look I got this email I don't
normally read emails it's been a long
time but I thought it was really nice
and uh I'll just read it from Sam he
says hey Michael it's Sam from Australia
I hope you're healthy and well I just
wanted to message you to let you know
that I've been listening and following
your inside of you podcast
and want to change and want to thank you
for changing my life listen to your
podcasts have inspired me and opened my
eyes to my own mental health and it's
all thanks to you I really appreciate
what you do thank you dude Sam
and I just thought that was really nice
you know if that's true that I can't
imagine
you know changing someone's life but if
if the show's doing that for you and if
it's helping you out it means a [__] ton
to me Sam
so that's really nice but when you said
change my brain went oh no he's going to
offer constructive criticism
but this wasn't ended up being way nicer
right oh you thought it was going to be
like oh he's gonna be I want to change
uh oh no yeah
yeah uh all right here are the top tier
patrons patreon.com inside you they give
a little more they get some cool stuff
swag YouTube lives patreon zooms I get
to ask questions on the uh to guests
blah blah blah join patreon today
patreon.com inside you hear the top
tiers Nancy D Leah s little Lisa you
Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert
B Jason W Sophie M Raj C Joshua D
Jennifer and Stacy l
Jamal F Janelle B Mike e l Don Supremo
Santiago correct Chad W Leanne P Janine
R Maya P Maddie s Belinda and Dave
H Sheila G Brad d Ray H Tabitha t
Tom and Liliana a Talia C
m m Betsy D Chad L angel
M Rhiannon C Corey
oh
it kind of goes with a Corey see okay K
is Right Corey K Dev Nixon Michelle
e d just think Canadian Michelle a
Jeremy
okay this is where it gets tricky r c
Jeremy C Brandy
uh just think think of her name
brand bran D Brenny D correct Joey no M
yeah this is Eugene and Leah correct
Corey Heather
see no actress Heather Locklear correct
Jake another actor that's weird
Jake G Jacob
oh B Busia busy Megan
m t Angela
B just think Angela forever I was
thinking of actors Mel
s Orlando see Caroline R Christine okay
no think Carolyn R Christine s in the
next letter Eric
H Shane
Shane R Andrew think of uh McMahon or
McCutchen or McCarthy Andrew McCarthy
Andrew M I know Andrew McMahon yeah yeah
okay yeah yeah I like him yeah Tim
Leonard yeah Karina Ann Amanda
r r gen B Kevin e Stephanie K Jarrell
Jammin J Leanne P again No E no l Jammin
J Leanne J correct Luna just think lunar
Luna owner lunar
Cindy think of her name
Lou Cindy
Cindy correct Mike
oh God h e f f think Mike Flanagan all
right Stone Cold Steve Austin H think
Stonehenge that makes sense Miss
just add another s Miss oh miss S Mrs
Ryan uh uh L L kdb Aaron R Kendall L
house J Meredith I Charlene C Kara C
Mary R Sheena L Jessica B Kyle F Marisol
P Estevan G Megan K Mickey L and Brian a
couldn't do it without you guys uh
thanks for listening hopefully you'll
tune in next week spread the word if you
can write a review if you can uh by this
point in the podcast only the
top tier is listening most likely
uh from the Hollywood Hills in Hollywood
California I am Michael Rosenberg
we love you guys uh be good to yourself
we'll see you
foreign